So that makes two wonderful evenings of
conversation
in one evening.
How many people were able to park without
difficulty coming here tonight?
And how many committed a violation in the
way they parked?
Let's start with of questions for Donald who
I think has some
very clear
and challenging
preachments for
the way we manage
pavement and cars in
many places including
Yale
and New Haven
and the state of Connecticut.
Tell us more how we can get rid of
on-site parking requirements.
This is complicated.
Well,
I was thinking as I was listening
to Tom,
it seemed to be one of the themes of what he said
was that driving seemed simple but was very complicated.
My view is that parking seems complicated
but is very simple.
And it would be much simpler if there
were no off-street parking requirements.
And I think
one of the
reasons I think that it can happen is that
some cities have already done it,
and a comparison I like to make
is between San Francisco and Los Angeles.
Some of you have heard of Disney Hall, the new concert
hall by Frank Gehry in
Los Angeles. Los Angeles requires as a minimum
fifty times more parking than San Francisco allows
as the maximum.
That in Los angeles we have a minimum with
no maximum, and
San Francisco has a maximum with no minimum.
Now if this were a real science,
wouldn't you ask what's going on?
If in one city the treatment
for tuberculosis was blood transfusion and
the city it was blood letting,
wouldn't any scientists say that there has
to be some mistake here?
But we have
most of the cities that you really want to
go to
like Boston and New York and Chicago and San Francisco
and London and Paris and Copenhagen,
they all have maximums with no minimums.
The cities that you don't want to go to
like Phoenix and Houston and Los Angeles,
they have minimums with no maximums,
so I think you have to decide what kind of
city you want to be more like, and
I think that we've had a long history
of trying to force up the parking supply
and not allowing anything that doesn't have
what we say is the
minimum.
I think you could just point to cities that you
would rather go to, and I think one of the cities
that I really like is
one of the best places on earth for pedestrians,
is Carmel, California
that doesn't allow any off-street in the
central business district.
They don't want any cars driving across sidewalks.
They want all the interior space used for shops
and art galleries. They think
there's more to be gained for the city
to have people park at the periphery and walk in. It's one of
the best places on Earth to be a pedestrian.
I'm not saying it's easy to do, but I think
that...
or I believe in the
Alice in Wonderland, once you say something
three times that it's true,
and I just have to keep saying it
over and over and over.
And I think more cities are trying it.
Other questions?
Don, I'm curious: there have been a few municipalities
mainly in the west
that have changed their parking policies
since your book came out,
and I'm wondering whether
there is much opposition
from the point of view of either
it chases potential customers away from business
areas, or that it costs too much
for people
who have very modest means.
Well, naturally I hear that question a lot.
And I've become, I hope,
practiced in answering it
because I do have
a second life of going to cities, giving my spiel,
and there's always somebody who gets up and it isn't a
question, they say, "I'll never
come back to downtown Santa Rosa if you
run the meters after 6 pm,"
and the argument I would make to the merchants
and the property owners--they seem very receptive--
is that
who do you think will spend more in a store or
leave a better tip at a restaurant?
Somebody who will come only if they can park
free after they drive around long enough
to find a space
or someone is willing to
pay for parking if they can easily
find a space?
Which will make the area
more prosperous? Say in old Pasadena when they put in
parking meters, the merchants thought
we're going to drive everybody away
once the city told the merchants and property owners you'll
get the revenue,
like that they said that's different, let's run the
meters until midnight. Let's run them on Sunday.
It's what you do with the money that is
very key. And if I really don't like
the person who asked the question, I say
if you aren't willing to pay for parking
downtown maybe you'll find you'll get a better
deal at the food court at a suburban mall with
ample free parking.
So everybody will win.
Let's get a question out of the front two rows.
Don, I'd like to ask you
what your opinion is about parking supply
at rail stations,
and how you
address the
supposed
demand issue there.
The local case may be
illustrative.
Well, you could probably predict what I'm going to say, and that
is to charge the right price for parking.
If all the spaces are full, the price should go up.
They're doing this in the San Francisco area, where
the BART system, the
Bay Area Rapid Transit system was supposed to
lead to wonderful development around
the stations, but instead there were just parking lots,
and they were
overflowing with cars.
I'd say there's something
different that I would say as well, it's that
not only charging the right price in the parking lots,
but I would say that
I haven't seen this happen really,
is that if there are permanent parking districts
around the station so that you can't park on the curb
on the street without
paying for it,
that you should allow the commuters
to pay for parking by the day.
But they would have to pay to park on the street,
and you would set the price so that
there are only
three or four
commuter cars on every block
and spend that money to improve the
neighborhood so that the parkers
and the residents
will be more symbiotic.
That the people who want to drive to the train
station
will be paying guests.
They won't be freeloaders anymore; they'll be paying
guests, and that's very different.
Many universities do this…well, not many, but some, like
the University of Colorado at Boulder, which does everything
right it seems…environmental things.
In all the surrounding neighborhoods they
do surveys to see if there are some
empty spaces during the day because almost
everybody has to work during the day
to make a living,
pay their mortgages in Boulder,
so that if there's less than
75% occupancy, they'll sell up to
four non-resident
daytime permits to
outsiders, and they charge them every month what
the residents have to pay for a year.
And the money is used to reduce the cost of the
permits for the residents. So I think we have
some of the most valuable land on earth now being
given away free to cars, and the more
you can figure out a way
make that land
pay for public services,
the better off we'll be.
In the back.
A number of the things you mentioned...
Well, as I understand it
if we start charging higher prices for parking
in the business district, will this
cause some people to park in the nearby neighborhoods?
Well,
most cities would give the residents a
permit to park at the meter
without paying.
That the residents usually get preference
in any district because they have to
be
bought off.
So I think to make it politically popular,
everybody who has as say, the residents,
the merchants and the property wonders, they all have
to be satisfied I think. And the way to satisfy
the residents
is to give them permit parking.
And that in these permit parking districts, if
there are some vacant spaces, you should sell the excess
to outsiders and use the money to improve the neighborhood.
And this is beginning to happen in cities, that they...
0:10:38.010,0:10:40.000
Here is some valuable land;
let's make use of it. The employees in stores can park
there during
the day,
and they'll pay for it or their employer will pay for it.
Let's pursue that
a little further, Don. Let's suppose we...
the city,
always in need of cash,
looks at all the
metered space or or meterable space on its streets,
and says let's have an auction.
Investors from everywhere,
hedge funds,
investment banks,
whomsoever,
we're going to sell all these street parking spaces,
and you can price it anyway you want.
Would we be prepared to make
that leap?
Well I wouldn't recommend it. Chicago
did do it, and the reason that they gave
was that they did not have the political
will to charge the
market rate prices for parking.
And they outsourced the need for political
will
to Morgan Stanley...
made over a billion dollars for
the media revenue for 75 years.
And it's a
perfect example-- I'm sure that would happen to any city.
They said we'll put this money into a lock
box, and we'll provide you know
revenue for schools or whatever for the next 75 years.
Within two years all the money was gone.
That's what we're doing everywhere is selling
off assets to pay for current expenses.
That's a bad idea for a household. It's a bad
idea for city.
If a city cannot get its act together and
manage its parking properly, maybe it should lease it
to a private operator. Maybe it should have
a revenue sharing agreement where they split the
revenue or something like that.
But I think its only if the city
says it can't do it,
that it doesn't have the capacity to do it,
then it should look to the outside
operators, but
they can be brought in as partners rather
than selling it all.
We're going to turn to Tom Vanderbilt in just a second,
but I thought it might be…Sure.
Don, in the slide I had from Perdue University,
one thing I forgot to
mention was that Pijanowsky found that
it's interesting
despite this abundance of parking, he found that
surveys still found that there was not
enough parking,
and I don't know if this is necessarily a peak demand
issue or...
It leads to the question or sort of the psychological
perception of what
is available parking and how that sort of plays,
and I was wondering if this has been
studied and to what extent and...
Yes it has. And parking is so much simpler than driving
that it's been studied very well
that whenever
there's a
place like West Hollywood, there's a hot
spot
in Los Angeles now, very trendy,
there's a terrible shortage of parking, including
off-street parking. We need more of it.
And I went into the parking garage, and you take
pictures of the ground floor spaces,
and they're just covered with oil spots.
You go up to the top deck,
and it looks as though there's never been a car
on it.
That's pristine, white
concrete, as though there's never been an oil spot.
I went to the top of the Temple Street garage.
I did not see a single oil spot.
I think that
the spaces that you can see
are the first spaces to be taken, and it
looks as though
there's a shortage, but when you go
to the spaces you can't see--there are a lot of them--
but getting back to my one note, I would say
the first spaces you see are the curb spaces.
And if they're all full, you think there's no parking.
And if we've got the price right for curb parking,
nobody could say there's a shortage of parking because
everywhere they went they would see one or two vacant spaces
on every block. They could never say there's
a shortage because…
well, some people would I suppose,
but most people wouldn't.
This is really
potent and interesting stop and persuasive
to me.
And ultimately there's a distributive side of this
where I mean people with
high need to park and low incomes
are going to get squeezed by the market mechanism
in this case as in
many other.
Are we prepared to
override that consideration, Don?
Well, I think I have a good answer for that as well
because it's obviously the first thing
that people say,
And I think I'm not accusing you of saying it,
but the people who don't want to pay for parking
they push poor people out in front of them
like human shields,
saying don't charge for parking, it'll hurt poor
people when they really mean don't charge for
parking because it will hurt me.
I could say that
some of the people who would
benefit most are the poorest
part of any population. New Haven has lots of
poor people. They could benefit from higher
public revenues.
Buses would run faster because
there wouldn't be so many cars
driving around, hunting for a free curb
parking space
and slowing down the buses. That's one of the
main reasons that San Francisco's doing it. They
justify it by it'll help poor people more than
anybody else.
Really poor people.
Okay, we've got a little time left and
another
fascinating argument.
Let's see what we can do with
questions directed to Tom Vanderbilt.
Thank you.
I want to take advantage of the fact that Tom
Vanderbilt is a journalist and there are other journalists
in the crowd.
I've been on a personal tear for some
time about the way we have refer to transit
as public transit or mass transit or public
transportation or mass transportation.
Nothing or hardly ever does a good
thing come after the word mass or after the word
public. So think murder and toilets
for example.
As a journalist I would love to
beg you to
only ever refer to transit as transit
ever. Thank you.
Good. Editorial acknowledged.
Questions out there. Yes, back right.
You'll have to bellow it out.
That would be a more
hopeful sign. Often, you know,
kids these days aren't really playing around
these signs because, you know, they're inside on their
Nintendos or whatever, but yeah.
Schools zones are a strange thing to
me. There's been some studies that
actually stop people after they've driven through a school
zone, they've tracked them on radar,
wondering how fast they were going, then asked them
how fast were you going.
They're off by ten miles an hour.
And this is
why I have a problem with certain…
in Texas for example there's new legislation, which
bans...
you can…how does it work in Texas…it now bans
hand held cellphone use in school zone areas,
but it's okay to use your hand held cellphone
everywhere else,
so this sort of assumes that number one you've seen the sign and
number two you're actually going to stop your conversation
right at the moment you enter this, so...
And it begs the question are you asking
people to drive in one manner here and then
back to less safely in other areas, so...
And clearly there's a reason some schools
need amplified school zone protection
because of the habits of children, but
yeah…This is the argument to go
back to the question about seeing things is
actually so much more potent than seeing a sign advising
of them, and the famous argument here is
Brian Arthur's safety
in numbers argument, which is basically that
the more you see of something,
the more likely you are to actually see that thing,
which has been
advanced to help explain why countries like
the Netherlands and
Denmark in addition to having better facilities
to begin with
have such lower
pedestrian and cyclist injury rates.
Drivers just are so accustomed to dealing with
and seeing them,
and it's sort of a nice
cycle: the more pedestrians you see, you sort of drive
slower and you see the pedestrians for a longer time.
Tom, I share your affinity for
incentive-based programs
and for
Thayer's approach
nudge and something like that, and I'm curious
if you've come across
any incentive-based programs
that you see that are actually working to impact certain
traffic patterns or negative traffic patterns that you've seen in the past.
Well, the obvious thing here would be congestion
pricing, which is a disincentive of course. but...
I'm trying to think of some of the things I've seen in the U.S.
has only been sort of hypothetical,
giving people for example… a program called
Choices…
done in the Puget Sound, Seattle area, which
gave people sort of an account.
an imaginary account of money that they could
based on the amount of miles they drove at the end of the
month they'd be given
some of that money back
based on if they drove at a different time,
off-peak, or if they just drove less in general.
And that program had
you know, pretty robust results.
People wanted
money back. And that was sort of hypothetical and it was
a congestion pricing lead-in
that never went anywhere, but when you...
You've got me for other...
Just a quick thing. I'm not saying that California
does anything right, but
one thing that I would recommend is called parking
cash out is that many employers give
their employees free parking
in California,
that if you have over fifty employees, and if you rent the
parking spaces to your employees, you have
to offer the employees the option to take
the cash value of the parking if they don't take
the parking.
It's not charging them for parking,
it just makes them aware they have an
alternative. They'd rather
ride the bus, ride transit
or if they'd rather bicycle or walk or carpool,
they could have the cash value of the parking.
The employer can't say I
will give you free parking or nothing,
which is what almost every employer the United
States does.
I think we have time for one or two
concluding questions. Yes.
Yeah, good observations. On the first one,
it's not a new observation that
people feel insulated from the environment
around them as they're driving a car,
even with the windows being up this
is something where even
cabin noise has been studied, and the absence of
cabin noise,
people actually drive faster.
On the second comment, it reminds me of
Safe Routes to School did a study of
traffic injuries for children around schools,
and the majority of kids were injured by
other parents taking their
kids to that same school.
And this is something again
comparing the early seventies to now, when I was
young, growing up in the suburbs
yet like the Bradys, I walked to school. This was not a
bizarre behavior...
Last question, George Edwards in the back.
The arrangement to which
the speaker referred is that the city
in 1991 leased
High Street and Wall Street the Yale for
99 years.
And the object was
to put cash in the city and
give the university planning control over
its interior streets.
And George,
I guess your objection is
what goes into the meters
does go to the city,
but the planning control is with Yale, and
I believe that you're a long-standing
opponent of that arrangement.
Okay,
we have a distinguished member of the audience
here from
Connecticut DOT and he's got a last question.
It's not so much a question as really an observation.
I'm John Murray with the Connecticut DOT.
Yes, we are going to expand parking capacity here
in New Haven as part of a larger vision
for transit-oriented development
around the station,
and given the current state of revenues here in Connecticut,
we are going to charge market rate for that
parking, and I can assure you of
all of that.
You mentioned Phoenix earlier today. Very
good observation. They actually recently built
a light rail system
in Phoenix, connecting Mesa through Tempe, to downtown Phoenix,
expected 17,000 riders per day on it. I worked on the system
and actually oversaw the
opening of the system.
I'm sorry.
And now the ridership
on that system despite free, ample parking
in downtown is 40,000 people per day.
The system just opened up in December 2008,
so as long as there's a good
alternative
to parking downtown, and that may be
public transportation,
there's ways in which we can achieve this. And lastly
the behavior that you talked about on
riders,
I wish I had been able to sort of document
this all the time,
and I hope my wife is not seeing this by
any chance, but she…We grew up in Boston, and she
didn't get her a driver's license until she was 32
years old because we moved from Boston. We actually
had to drive cars,
and she went from being a raving lunatic
and quite honestly I really
hope she's not watching this. She's a lawyer.
It'd be very bad for me.
But her behavior since we moved back
to a more transit-friendly Connecticut
is much better, and she's in a much better mood
for all that, so.
Thanks, and let's have a round of applause for these
wonderful speakers.